two moves this is deadly this is a check
the black king has no Escape squares
thanks to this white Pawn actually this
white porn doing a good job of cutting
it off and Checkmate so Magnus had to
run away with this Rook but now he's a
whole piece down and the attack is
likely to continue uh I mean that's
surely going to be an attack against the
black king on one or two squares you can
offer a trade of Queens yeah try to put
it in the bank as I like to say do we
want to trade off the Queens do we not
want to go for checkmate
like the swirling in his chair doesn't
even want to look at this Magnus Carlson
yeah so you guys are suggesting for
example this move yeah
firstly Queen trade secondly going for
this Pawn we just remember that there's
a Pawn on E6
become a second going yeah maybe this is
a good move maybe Magnus looks like a
great move to Me Maybe Magnus is one
trap is after Queen to this Square he'll
give a check I guess and maybe he'll
take the White Knight
um because if the queen is captured now
then suddenly it's white who gets
checkmated